qu'est ce que vous disent les retraités
autour de vous les personnes âgées que
vous côtoyez sur cette réforme des
retraites
qu'est ce qu'ils redoutent parce qu'ils
redoutent c'est leur avenir
bon là je est allongé on vient de plus
en plus tard on vit de plus en plus
longtemps
bon et cette réforme la majorité de nos
retraités et la majorité les français
n'en veulent pas on ne sait pas ce que
ça va donner en fin de compte cette
retraite à points on ne connaît pas la
valeur
enfin comment va être calculée le point
est-ce que ça va être l'heure parce que
ça va être bercy on est on est encore
dans le flou est total et tout le monde
dit ce gouvernement nous méprisent
complètement nous les retraités on est
vraiment on dit les nantis on est loin
d'être anti vous savez à moins de 1000
euros de retraite par mois
si on appelle ça être nanti non c'est
trop c'est trop naze nous ce qu'on
demande
il y avait deux solutions ou remettre
cette réforme complètement à plat en
rediscuter ou suppression de nombre de
ces traitements couleurs y avait le
référendum mais moi je sais plus à la
limite on met cette réforme à plat et on
en discute avec les pertes d'air sociaux
boudés discute sérieusement
alors justement michel dago mais les
retraités qui sont autour de vous est ce
que selon vous ils ont été assez
entendus pendant toute la période de
dialogue et de discussion avec non non
on n'est pas du tout du tout
entendue voilà j'ai participé à
pratiquement toutes les manifestations
comme je le pouvais bon et puis nos
collègues de des transports bon je
pouvais pas toujours et participer mais
quand je rencontre mois des personnes
qui ont 80 ans qui sont encore dans les
rues à manifester je trouve que c'est
quand même dramatique
justement on a vu aujourd'hui énormément
de monde encore dans les rues est ce que
c'est symbolique où c'est nécessaire
alors symbolique c'est notre
gouvernement qui prend ça de très haut
mais moi je dis que c'est nécessaire il
faut qu'on se bat aussi bien nos jeunes
aussi bien les actifs que nous les
retraités ce que bon à quelle sauce on
va être mangé pour l'instant on ne le
sait pas ce plan il est maintenant est
dans le flou on ne on ne sait rien de
notre devenir
alors la porte parole du gouvernement
disait à la fin du mois justement que le
rejet de cette réforme était dû à un
manque de compréhension de la part des
français qui est bien sûr mais parce que
tout n'est menée en novembre du
gouvernement ne l'ont très mal expliqué
on se pose même la question si eux mêmes
ça veut le devenir de cette réforme
aujourd'hui il ya un phénomène qui se
multiplient c'est à dire que les
personnes qui sont à la retraite et bien
je travaille en parallèle pour les idées
des petits boulots en intérim
est ce qu'avec cette réforme selon vous
on se dirigerait justement vers
finalement une multiplication de deux
retraités beaucoup plus de retraités qui
sera obligé de travailler pour pouvoir
vie mais certainement on nous parle qu
on maintient la retraite à 62 ans on ne
parlait de cet âge pivot qui n'est
malgré tout pas retiré qui est
en attente dans le projet alors 62 ans
non au fond mieux de dire ses 64 ans
puisque 62 ans si on perd à 62 ans il y
aura une décote jusqu'à 64 alors là là
aussi ce sont des mensonges de la part
de nos chers gouvernants
alors olivier verront le nouveau
ministre de la santé vient de s'exprimer
à l'instant je le cite il vante une
ambition immense pour vous une ambition
immense une ambition réussi ça passerait
par quoi dans ce dossier de la réforme
des retraites ça passerait par quoi déjà
qu'on est d'aider des retraites dignes
de ce nom qu'il y ait plus de retraite
inférieure 1000 euros et encore mille
euros nous ensemble et solidaires unirs
pernoud on préconise une retraite
minimum à 1200 euros
bien sûr pour une carrière complète donc
voilà déjà là ce sera déjà un bon point
le président de l'art de la république à
manuel macron en tout cas il se dit que
emmanuel macron ne serait pas opposée 1
49 3 faire passer le projet en force
qu'est ce que c'est ce qui va se passer
malheureusement vous pensez oui oui
malheureusement on va en arriver là
parce que cette ce plan de réforme il
est ficelé et je crois que
aussi bien le président de la république
que le premier ministre et tous les
membres du gouvernement ne reviendrons
pas en arrière
donc effectivement ils passeront en
force mais on se battra on se battre
qu'est ce que vous attendez des députés
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle c'est eux
qui vont y prendre la main oui mais
l'opposition notamment le l'opposition
bon effectivement mais on dit bien
l'opposition ils sont minoritaires
qu'est ce que vous voulez cliquez qu'on
en sorte de plus de toute façon cette
majorité se moque un petit peu de nous
on est méprisé aussi bien par le
président de la république que pour de
cette chambre de députés qui est
majoritaire lrm c'est ça aujourd'hui qui
vous marquent c'est le mépris
oui les retraités par le gouvernement
oui oui oui vous avez été reçus à vous
même vous le disiez puisque vous disiez
comment est ce que vous avez perçu
finalement les discussions vous avez que
vous avez eues on n'en tient pas compte
bon on a été reçu par une députée pour
ne pas la nommer corinne vignon bon qui
nous a écoutés effectivement on fait que
nous écouter et n'en tient pas compte de
nos revendications de ce qu'on dit pour
vous oui pour vous les nécessaires
aujourd'hui que la rue continue à
s'exprimer mal malgré ce 49 3 qui pour
we will je crois que il faut il faut
continuer il y a que comme ça qu'on
arrivera quelque chose mais bon
effectivement je vous dis c'est c'est
pratiquement impossible ce gouvernement
est résigné il va appliquer ce qu'il a
envie d'appliquer voit bien ce qui s'est
passé delevoye il a fait ça un petit peu
en cas de toux me dit voilà bon les
aides les partenaires sociaux on les
invite pour dire qu'on les a vite mais
ça va
pour conclure elle a été suffisamment
bien ficelé
cette loi ce projet de loi en tout cas
on a vu un l'avis du conseil d'état on a
vu plusieurs spécialistes assez
réticents oui dit il a manqué selon vous
du dialogue comme aux habitants il a
manqué énormément de de dialogue et puis
on nous écoute pas merci beaucoup
michel dagbert d'avoir accepté notre
invitation girel que vous avez été
notamment membre 1
de l'union nationale des retraités et
des personnes âgées
merci